hi I'm reto Meier Google developer
advocate today I learned that every car
crash three one one call three city bike
tripping station and limousine ride in
New York City is available as public
data sets in Google bigquery you know on
which New York City streets you'll most
likely to find a loud party may be the
one place where a collision caused by an
animal also injured a cyclist or the
city black record for the longest
distance written in the shortest time
one of the amazing things about working
at Google is the ability to do whatever
is necessary to find answers so let's
test the New York or to this computer
representation of New York from Pierre
in San Francisco after all what better
way is there to get to know new york
city even by immersing yourself in the
hustle and bustle of data analysis and
visualization as representing its eight
and a half million residents and fifty
million yearly visitors for example in
2016 these city streets witnessed a lot
of traffic accidents there are over two
hundred thousand motor vehicle
collisions across the five boroughs
resulting in over fifty thousand
injuries and 200 deaths mainly due to
drive inattention and motorcyclists
being the most likely to die in the case
of a collision when the temperature in
New York drops New Yorkers retreat
inside and call 3-1-1 about the snow or
lack of heat and hot water especially in
the Bronx all across New York people are
concerned with the noise and the
condition of the city streets but when
you normalize the results by the size of
each virus population you see that the
people of Staten Island have the biggest
infrastructure issues no matter the
weather is the potholes rough cracked
roads and cave-ins that have Staten
Islanders calling three on one if it's a
Wednesday the people of New York are
taking lots of short rides on their city
bikes since 2013 there's been over 33
million city bike rides averaging 15
minutes per ride ride a skew 76 percent
men to 24% women and with 62% of all
riders aged between 27 and 41 with this
route alongside the Hudson by far the
most popular using these pre-loaded
public datasets you can investigate
almost every aspect of the city by
analyzing survey data you can just
in 1995 the most commentary in New York
was the Norway maple with over a hundred
thousand trees and that by 2005 it was
overtaken by the London plain tree as
always your first terabyte of processing
is free meaning you can run all the
queries i've shown you and many more at
no cost
sign up was financially query today and
create your own yield city visualization
kevin with us using this today I learned
with bigquery hashtag and of course
subscribe to our channel follow our blog
to learn something new with bigquery